[dance music]
♪ ♪
- OH, DAMN!
CHECK THAT [bleep] OUT.
- WHAT IS THAT?
- WHOO!
I DIDN'T KNOW
THEY MADE 'EM LIKE THAT.
[laughs]
- I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SEEING.
- MM. WHOO-WHOO!
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
WHAT'S UNDER THERE.
- I AM REALLY CURIOUS
ABOUT THAT.
- [laughs]
YEAH, DOG, YEAH.
- I MEAN, I HAVE NO IDEA.
- WELL, YOU KNOW, WE, UH--
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE SOME IDEA,
YOU KNOW?
- I DON'T.
- WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S, UH--
YOU KNOW, IT'S A COOCHIE, BABY.
- YEAH.
OR SOMETHING.
- UH, NO, NO, NO, MAN.
IT'S--IT'S DEFINITELY
HER LADY PARTS.
[laughs]
- OR, MAYBE
IT'S JUST MORE SKIN.
- NOPE.
IT--IT'S A VAGINA.
- YEAH. OR, MAYBE IT'S
A LITTLE FACE UNDER THERE.
- UH, NO. NO, IT'S--IT'S
DEFINITELY GONNA BE A VAGINA.
- WHY?
- BE--BECAUSE SHE'S A GIRL,
AND GIRLS HAVE VAGINAS, MAN.
- WHAT IS THAT?
- WHAT IS A VAGINA?
IT'S A WOMAN'S
REPRODUCTIVE ORGAN.
WHA--ARE YOU BEING SERIOUS
RIGHT NOW?
[eerie music]
- [deep voice] THANK YOU.
THAT IS ALL I REQUIRE.
[shimmering]
- OH!
OH, [bleep].
THERE'S ALIENS!
THERE'S A ALIEN DOWN THERE.